Secretario Sala Penal 5 V: Buenas tardes, se va a convocar a la audiencia de apelación
Secretario Sala Penal 5 V: incidental dentro del proceso que sigue el Ministerio Público en contra del
Secretario Sala Penal 5 V: en contra de la persona vanesa yeseña. Yupanqui quisver y celia victoria. Yupanqui quisbert.
Secretario Sala Penal 5 V: Se consulta a las partes que están presentes en la sala virtual se encuentra representante del Ministerio público.
Fis. Willy Bejarano: Buenas tardes. Doctor: ¡Sí! Evidentemente Ministerio Público: presente.
Secretario Sala Penal 5 V: Doctor Willy bejarano, no doc.
Fis. Willy Bejarano: Muy liberal. Sí, creo que.
Secretario Sala Penal 5 V: Doctor, Gracias.
Secretario Sala Penal 5 V: Se encuentra la parte imputada vanesa yesenia Yupanquisbert.
Jose Brando Zamorano Thames: Sí, señor Secretario. Sí, doctor, se presenta Vanesa, yacena yupanqui.
Secretario Sala Penal 5 V: La señora Celia Victoria Iuán, Kisbert.
Jose Brando Zamorano Thames: Sí, doctor. Estoy presente.
Secretario Sala Penal 5 V: Está bien. Gracias.
Secretario Sala Penal 5 V: Se encuentra su abogado, el doctor José Zamorano, tamos.
Jose Brando Zamorano Thames: Ahme. Sí, señor Secretario presente. Muchas gracias.
Secretario Sala Penal 5 V: Está bien. Doctor.
Jose Brando Zamorano Thames: Muchas gracias.
Secretario Sala Penal 5 V: Gracias doctor.
Secretario Sala Penal 5 V: Se encuentra la parte víctima modesta, dominga Yufanki quisbert.
Abogado Carlos Moscoso García: Doctor, buenas tardes, encuentro algo presente, señora modesta yupanqui.
Secretario Sala Penal 5 V: Muchas gracias, señor Modesta. El doctor Carlos Eduardo Moscoso García.
Abogado Carlos Moscoso García: Presidente, doctor abogado Carcelado Moscas García, abogada de la parte víctima.
Secretario Sala Penal 5 V: Muchas gracias. Doctor, por favor, Voy a rogarles que esperemos en la sala virtual.
Secretario Sala Penal 5 V: al llamado del vocal que va a presidir las la presunta audiencia.
VOCAL  JUAN ADALIT MAMANI: Te gustaría. Por favor, iniciaremos grabación
VOCAL  JUAN ADALIT MAMANI: que querían escuchar.
Secretario Sala Penal 5 V: La palabra, señor vocal de la revisión de legajo de apelación.
Secretario Sala Penal 5 V: Se tiene que ser cumplido con la legal notificación de todas las partes procesales
Secretario Sala Penal 5 V: encontrándose presentes en sala, El representante del ministerio público doctor Willy bejarano vizcarra. Asimismo, se encuentra la parte imputada Vanesa Yesenia Yupanqui Quisbert y celia Victoria Yupaquisbert, quienes son apelantes asistidos por su abogado. El Dr.
Secretario Sala Penal 5 V: José zamorano Tamez Asimismo, se encuentra la parte víctima Modesta Domínguez Yupanqui Gilbert, asistida por su abogado, el doctor Carlos Eduardo Morcoso García. Asimismo, se hace constar que se encuentra también presente en la sala virtual. El vocal presidente de esta sala, doctor Henry Sánchez, es cuando tengo que informar a su digna autoridad.
VOCAL  JUAN ADALIT MAMANI: Téngase presente en este caso. Conforme se tiene de el informe de secretaría de Cámara C.
VOCAL  JUAN ADALIT MAMANI: Se han cumplido con las formalidades de ley y aclarar a las partes de que
VOCAL  JUAN ADALIT MAMANI: dentro del trámite de esta causa ya hay una suspensión de audiencia que ha sido impetrada por parte de la ciudadana Celia Victoria yubanqui y vanesa Yesine.
VOCAL  JUAN ADALIT MAMANI: y que debió haber sido desarrollada en fecha 27 de octubre del año, 2 025 con la anterior vocal. Por otra parte, también señalar que por su composición de sala plena, se me ha asignado sus ojos
VOCAL  JUAN ADALIT MAMANI: componer la sala por la sala penal quinta conjuntamente el doctor Henry
VOCAL  JUAN ADALIT MAMANI: Hensy Sánchez: No consecuencia con estas aclaraciones, vamos a continuar la audiencia de
VOCAL  JUAN ADALIT MAMANI: la apelación incidental a la resolución número 2, 83 quebrado 2 023 que ha sido emitida por parte del juzgado de instrucción penal. Uno de la localidad de viacha del departamento de la paz
VOCAL  JUAN ADALIT MAMANI: y concretamente, la parte impetrante o apelante es
VOCAL  JUAN ADALIT MAMANI: el abogado en este caso de los 2 imputados o del imputado entre comillas, No consecuencia, por favor, amplíe el informe si se encuentra el 8 al doctor Secretario de Cámara.
VOCAL  JUAN ADALIT MAMANI: está. Estamos, no entonces tiene la palabra el abogado, La parte de papel ante la voy a conceder 5 minu 7 min a fin de que pueda expresar sus agravios de acuerdo al artículo 3 98. Ya tiene la palabra Doctor: cumpliremos con instructivo 0, 7 que va de 2 023, que es de que deben activar su cámara y micrófono a momentos de su intervención.
Jose Brando Zamorano Thames: Gracias, señor juez haciendo caso a lo que su autoridad está determinando. Señor Vocal referirla, señor Vocal, que evidentemente se ha planteado apelación a la resolución. 283 y apelación incidental que observaba en ese entonces la resolución de imputación formal no resolución que data del 6 del 4 de de julio de 2 025. Señor juez al presente, señor juez, habiendo transcurrido bastante
Jose Brando Zamorano Thames: de tiempo.
Jose Brando Zamorano Thames: En tanto las señoras Jessica Yesenia
Jose Brando Zamorano Thames: Yupanqui, la ciudad de la serie victoria yupanqui deciden retirar el recurso de apelación por la data del tiempo, señor Juez, por lo que en este momento estaría retirando el planteamiento de la apelación incidental, planteada en fecha 4 de Julio de 2 025.
VOCAL  JUAN ADALIT MAMANI: En ese presente se le agradece por esa lealtad cruzada al abogado zamorano. En este caso corresponde directamente sin otorgar la palabra al señor representante del Ministerio público, como tampoco al abogado de la parte víctima, toda vez de que no son apelantes. Conforme se tiene el Acta
VOCAL  JUAN ADALIT MAMANI: que se ha labrado en fecha 4 de junio del año 2 025, corresponde emitir la correspondiente el correspondiente auto de vista. Por favor. Secretario.
Abogado Carlos Moscoso García: Previo.
VOCAL  JUAN ADALIT MAMANI: Sí, el abogado Carlos Moscoso García, Doctor.
Abogado Carlos Moscoso García: A fines de registro abogado de Moscús, García, abogado la parte víctima en este caso, si bien se ha impetrado y se ha emitido un recurso de apelación por la parte, en este caso imputada. Voy a pedirle a su autoridad, considere que, al haber retirado la la
Abogado Carlos Moscoso García: el recurso de apelación a la imputación que tiene ya las 2 imputadas. Este recurso se tiene que considerar como dilatorio. Voy a pedir a su propiedad distinguido vocal, se aplique el artículo 100
Abogado Carlos Moscoso García: 5 del código procesal penal, y es que sería un incidente malicioso, su probidad emite lo que en derecho corresponde es lo que todo lo que tengo a bien solicitar autoridad.
VOCAL  JUAN ADALIT MAMANI: Téngase presente lo manifestado prólogo a la víctima.
VOCAL  JUAN ADALIT MAMANI: Bueno, vamos a emitir el correspondiente auto de vista
VOCAL  JUAN ADALIT MAMANI: la sala penal quinta del Tribunal Departamental de Justicia, auto divisa consideración al recurso de apelación incidental a la resolución número 283, que era 2 025
VOCAL  JUAN ADALIT MAMANI: a 19 de junio del año, 2 025 vistos. Considerando 1 antecedentes
VOCAL  JUAN ADALIT MAMANI: conforme se tiene el legajo de apelación que ha sido sorteada a esta sala penal quinta, se tiene que el juzgado de instrucción de lo penal. Uno debía echar el departamento de la Paz ha emitido la resolución número 2, 83 quebrado 2 025
VOCAL  JUAN ADALIT MAMANI: en fecha 4 de junio del año, 2 025, donde el juez cautelar ha dispuesto declarar infundado el incidente de actividad procesal defectuosa, absoluta de nulidad a la resolución de imputación formal.
VOCAL  JUAN ADALIT MAMANI: no debían estar las partes al estado del proceso.
VOCAL  JUAN ADALIT MAMANI: Posteriormente, conforme se obtiene de la resolución, el abogado, en este caso del imputado al amparo de la tribu. 403 del código procedimiento penal
VOCAL  JUAN ADALIT MAMANI: ha interpuesto de forma oral el correspondiente recurso de apelación incidental contra esta resolución.
VOCAL  JUAN ADALIT MAMANI: Protestando en esta audiencia, que va a fundamentar los agravios en esta audiencia en este tribunal de alzada
VOCAL  JUAN ADALIT MAMANI: por lo que, al haber en este caso concedido la palabra al abogado de ambas imputadas.
VOCAL  JUAN ADALIT MAMANI: Él mismo se refiere por la data de la resolución. En la actualidad va a retirar el correspondiente recurso de apelación incidental, por lo que corresponde ingresar como consideramos 2 a las conclusiones.
VOCAL  JUAN ADALIT MAMANI: En este caso es importante considerar el artículo 3 98 del Código procedimiento penal que establece la competencia de los tribunales de alzada.
VOCAL  JUAN ADALIT MAMANI: estableciendo que los tribunales de alzada circunscribirán sus resoluciones a los aspectos cuestionados de la resurrección.
VOCAL  JUAN ADALIT MAMANI: En el caso presente, al haber retirado, no hay ningún agravio que ha sido debidamente fundamental. Más al contrario, el abogado de la defensa ha retirado sus recursos de apelación. En consecuencia, está
VOCAL  JUAN ADALIT MAMANI: de acuerdo con todos los fundamentos que han sido esgrimidos en la resolución número 283 quebrado 2 025 por lo que corresponde confirmar esta resolución. Por tanto, la sala penal quinta la
VOCAL  JUAN ADALIT MAMANI: dispone primero la admisibilidad del recurso al haber sido interpuesto dentro plazo de ley
VOCAL  JUAN ADALIT MAMANI: y al no haberse establecido ningún agravio por la parte apelante, se va en este caso confirmar la resolución número 283 quebrado 2 025 en todos sus fundamentos.
VOCAL  JUAN ADALIT MAMANI: Respecto a la solicitud del abogado de la defensa. En este caso, esta autoridad establece de que no existe un incidente manifiestamente dilatorio.
VOCAL  JUAN ADALIT MAMANI: pero, de volverse a incurrir en presentar estos incidentes por una segunda oportunidad, sí se establecería que es manifiestamente dilatorio. En consecuencia, únicamente se llama la atención a las partes apelantes, porque se ha destinado un tiempo para considerar estos agravios.
VOCAL  JUAN ADALIT MAMANI: no en consecuencia, regístrese con el presidente auto de vista. Se notifica al ministerio público, doctor Willy beragrano, se notifica al abogado de la parte víctima, como también al abogado de ambos acusados.
VOCAL  JUAN ADALIT MAMANI: Ha concluido la audiencia, tengan buenas tardes a las.
Jose Brando Zamorano Thames: Gracias, señor Bocados.
Fis. Willy Bejarano: Gracias. Doctor.